what is happening there reject nation
damn it we're going to watch today from
new rock stars marvel's what if episode
one easter eggs and breakdown come on
man
the eric vos follow this man on twitter
while you're at it i petition that he
deserves a cameo and a marvel property i
believe he's earned it if we're gonna
see gamers and free guy we should start
seeing some eric boss and some marvel
what property would you want eric voss
to appear in put that in the comments
down below that's that should be the
main talked about thing let's do this
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of what if
episode 1 which ponders the question
what if peggy carter became a super
soldier instead of steve rogers but also
what if steve rogers became the first
iron man what if nick fury and hawkeye
had to clean squid chunks out of the
project pegasus basement and what if
jeffrey wright was watching you from
space right now you'd prefer that
wouldn't you i would i was honestly
pretty surprised how many mcu
connections and mythology they were able
to work into this show so i'm gonna
break down all the easter eggs and
subtle animation details that you might
have missed and some theories for how
this really could tie into the live
action mcu as the show's creators of
indicated marvel studios
that's what i will be the marvel studios
title which shifts into animated brush
strokes as a way of signaling to us that
we are still in the marvel cinematic
universe of the films with the voices of
mostly the same actors or actors trying
to emulate them just one that visually
appears in a different medium similar to
how animated star wars series are every
bit as canon as the films in the
mandalorian are the voice of jeffrey
wright as uwatu the watcher guides us
through the opening titles
time
space
reality
it's more than a linear path time space
and reality are all abstract concepts
with infinity stone counterparts and may
be also a clue for the universal
constants that this series will treat as
variables instead placing characters in
variable times variable points in space
variable realities now the watchers are
marvel cosmic entities who observe and
record history throughout the multiverse
watching the watcher is assigned to our
universe which is why uatu is the one
narrating to us right now watchers
actually made live-action cameos in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. they were
stuck listening to stan lee's stories
which was a not the fan theory that stan
lee's various mcu cameos could have made
him uwatu really stan lee was probably
closer to entities like the one above
all which was an unseen meta figure that
was likened to artist jack kirby he's
just stan lee you know what would be
funny though is if they decided george
lucas this on disney plus were guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 is put
jeffrey right in there instead
supplement one of them out of there it
would piss people off but it'll make me
happy yeah make everything as uniform as
possible
no signs of this little thumb prints
along the way weird cgi jeffrey wright i
petition this but huanche's appearance
here is a red outlined silhouette in
space not the flesh-colored heads of the
comics he actually looks more like the
marvel entity known as eternity which
was the living embodiment of the
universe itself a shattered prism shows
moments from the upcoming season and one
of those moments captain carter itself
contains infinite variables within
reflecting how this one altered choice
by peggy carter also leads to several
other variances that we see in this
episode and can imagine beyond this
episode's ending then we open on the
events of the first cat film which was
itself visually stylized with
desaturation to evoke a nostalgic
quality the animation on what if is
designed with the same idea in mind with
director brian andrews citing the work
of artist j.c liondecker from the 1920s
and 30s for simple but life-like 2d
characters and that warmness is
heightened in this opening scene with
this random bright beam of sunlight on
steve even though the scene that they
base it on was in a windowless dimly lit
lab yes it's one of my favorite
qualities about this episode in
particular and i don't know how much the
other episodes will ape this because i
was kind of surprised by how specific
the animation was to feeling kind of
like a 1940 strip i looked at the other
footage of the what we got in the
trailers and they don't seem to evoke
that same type of emotional correlation
i mean it seems like they really pumped
up the bloom too to make all the
figurative camera look like an old glass
camera you know so uh yeah maybe the
next ones will feature more futuristic
cinematic flourishes but also during
that opening prologue we dissolve from
cap's shield to the planet of earth
superimposing the shield over the entire
world the way this shield metaphorically
became a suit of armor around the world
hayley atwell returns to voice peggy
carter steve is actually voiced by actor
josh keaton who sounds a hell of a lot
like chris evans does josh keaton
spectacular spider-man spectacular
spectacular spider-man
i've only seen one episode i'm just
kidding
[Laughter]
stanley tucci and dominic cooper return
as dr erskine and howard stark and tommy
lee jones character colonel phillips
appears but he doesn't speak but then
the key variant moment occurs no i'd
prefer to stay
there
that's the moment
that created a new universe now that was
a throwaway line in the original captain
america film agent carter don't you
think you would be more comfortable in
the booth oh yes of course sorry but
whereas peggy watched from the
observation deck there here she stays
see i'd love the littlest attention to
detail like that the butterfly effect of
this whole situation came off of a
moment that you would only really
remember if you really remember the
movie because it is such a throwaway
line but that one little choice you know
like i actually had to jog my memory a
little bit in real time of like oh yeah
like i remembered it a little bit later
moments after but yeah that's that's uh
that's my favorite kind of butterfly
effect like where it's just the tiniest
slither it's a little yes instead of a
no which also leads to everyone else who
is in that booth staying on the floor
too including the hydra assassin whose
bomb is now right beside erskine's foot
causing him to get killed in the blast
and not be shot by him right after
colonel phillips also gets shot and
killed along with steve though he
survives and peggy shoots and kills the
assassin right there preventing the need
for a street chase that superpower with
steve rogers would have gone on but
remember in that movie peggy carter had
that assassin dead in her sights and she
would have killed him had steve not
tackled her so peggy steps into the
chamber powering herself up in a
sequence matching the storyboard of the
film
[Music]
colonel flynn a new character voiced by
bradley whitford chews her out
afterwards every last drop of that dr
erskine serum went into you and if we
get lucky someday your blood might tell
us how to make a real super soldier wait
a minute i heard a lot of people in our
comments and are all these people wrong
colonel flynn is actually from the show
agent carter so it's not a brand new
character uh-oh
so eric voss i do not want you to
experience this loss but
might have to toss
the new character
sentence i ran out of things that rhymed
with
some some uh some clown
boss kate kate bo
kate moss yeah look at those vials of
blood they're taking out by my count i
see 19 of them plus two more that
they're doing just seems like a whole
bunch of loose ends that could set up
future government experiments with peggy
carter's blood now in the live action
mcu the attempts to restart the super
soldier experiment included general ross
turning bruce banner into the hulk along
with emil blonsky into a super soldier
who eventually became abomination and
according to the fact of the winter
soldier there were similar experiments
going on linked with isaiah bradley but
in this case peggy carter's blood could
be the basis of characters like baddies
ross becoming red hulk maybe even bruce
banner's cousin jennifer walters
becoming she-hul then peggy boxes and
knocks the bag off the rigging just like
live-action steve did when he was
restless and she kick flips a weight and
frisbees it into the wall just like the
big kickflip move in captain america
winter soldier and she's just showing
that she is ready for the shield
meanwhile wounded steve does physical
therapy similar to rhodey at the end of
civil war but like roadie steve has a
future in a stark designed armored suit
great correlation
and compared to that establishing shot
now the church's front light is not lit
but still schmidt rolls up and alternate
universe the same close-up of his
modified ben's hood ornament with the
hydra logo now ross marquan voices red
skull he actually took over the roll
from hugo weaving when red skull
returned an infinity war the wooden
engraving of the yejirso world's tree
here is way bigger and schmidt's hand
runs across a new section that was not
in the film a ring with a tesseract in
the middle and tentacles sneaking out of
course foreshadowing how he will use the
tesseract to open a portal for the
interdimensional champion to arrive
through but really all of this is a way
of showing that here schmidt's end goal
for the tesseract is not world
domination under the hydra flag really
reaching out into the cosmos which is a
bit ironic because in the movie red
skull did end up blasted out into space
here he ends up dead on earth peggy
howard and colonel flynn review the
tesseract in a textbook and above that
illustration are some norse runes and
that's what's the case with loki
marvel's norse alphabet is all over the
place because this seems to translate to
gibberish but the caption beneath is
italian that translates to the hypercube
in the true shape of the space stone
whoa the fact that the tesseract
contained an infinity stone did not seem
to be public knowledge though who knows
this textbook could contain some
references or citations from the italian
book of cagliostro which contain
knowledge about the time stone in the
ivagimoto so i don't know maybe infinity
stones were some ancient knowledge on
earth just known by certain people what
doesn't matter they're all paper weights
anyway yeah they don't have any bearing
on the cinematic universe yeah it
doesn't matter anymore it's totally
yeah but on a serious note though very
serious as a serious talks would have it
right now what if because you know how
in loki they you see variations of uh
all the infinity stones like there's
multiples of them so what if it's just
in this case this space stone is
contained within the tesseract or does
that not apply with everyone's fictional
multiverse rules here it seems
reasonable to assert here they could
show up in one iteration in one universe
maybe this is just its natural way in
this universe howard gives her her new
suit in a box labeled howard's designer
clothing and also her own shield which
instead of the stars and stripes now
bears iconography of the union jack and
notice how there's a blue stripe on the
outer edge instead of the red one on cap
shield so carter suits up and stops
arnhem zola at berlin's brandenburg gate
and we hear her theme music
[Music]
which is a slightly altered version of
the captain america theme
[Music]
yeah peggy's is the woke for it yeah
that's way woker no it's
a wokeness melody is like so much more
progressive just got their hands on the
instruments every time i hear it i just
want to go outside and put on a dress or
something you know you know one thing
that i completely forgot to mention when
we were doing our review the music in
here is exceptional it is up there with
some like great mcu music and that was
something that i was actually kind of
surprised to see in in the animated show
i don't know why that was like the last
thing i was expecting i kind of hold
that um expectation towards falcon
winter soldier and loki loki i thought
really delivered but what if and i
imagine that since we're going to be
getting different characters from
different parts of the mcu to focus on
just how much variety of music we'll
actually get this time around so i'm
actually really excited for that and
again i really like how they use
lighting in this case to give dimension
to these otherwise 2d characters to make
their movements look more fluid and pop
off the screen like notice how whenever
carter makes a power move she's always
illuminated by one of the headlights one
of the cars she's stopping or has just
flipped over the end result is to
outline her in this white glow and also
creating a really nice glare off her
shield carter walks away from this with
the tesseract and howard uses it to
power the hydra stomper armor for steve
i'm not sure why it would have to be
steve who gets to pilot it i don't know
having a tiny test pilot would be useful
to lighten the overall load now in the
film howard does experiment briefly on
the tesseract for weapons purposes but
while this episode doesn't really go
into it it is hugely significant for
howard to build a flying suit of armor
essentially an iron man mark 1 prototype
decades before his son would do so
carter rescues the 107th approaching on
a motorcycle placing her shield in front
of her just like how steve does in the
other scene in the movie and inside we
meet the howling commandos including dum
dum duggan actually neil mcdonough
returns to voice in here there's also
james montgomery fallsworth gabe jones
jacques daniele jim morita and bucky
barnes sebastian stan voices a few
one-liners in this episode that uh well
reminded me that i'm an adult watching a
kid's show there's the famous
film and steve drops in with the hydra
stomper actually i love how inside his
face appears surrounded by a heads-up
display similar to the close-ups of tony
stark inside the iron man helmet but
instead of the digital projections
they're all analog i love that i love
that zap's a tank and it blows up but
for one frame the blast recolors are
shot in all white and then all black
just a cool way of showing the
brightness of the explosion that is
powered by infinity stone steve says
let's hear it for captain carter which
bucky said for steve in the movie let's
hear it for captain america
i forgot about that
shot that follows carter all the way
from outside through the cockpit i love
this shot and she fights her way through
the cabin then up through the hatch and
then down the tail some fun storyboarded
action here a nazi general snaps at red
skull captain carter and this so-called
hydro stomper are wreaking havoc this is
actually a vocal cameo by snl actor
turned snl announcer daryl hammond
carter rogers oh really yeah i saw his
name i wonder who's a good whiskey
but the serum doesn't allow me to feel
the effects kind of a reversal of the
scene in the film i can't get drunk did
you know that
your metabolism burns four times faster
than the average person then they staged
this train mission just like the one in
the film but carter calls it here
operation where eagles dare a reference
to the 1968 world war ii film that was
also set in the alps and bucky almost
falls as he does in the live-action
version but carter saves him
thanks you almost ripped my arm off yeah
we we we get it buggy you lose your arm
sarah
eric was waiting just to see bucky in
this episode forget captain carter i
wouldn't want anyone else to play bucky
here i will also say that there was
something kind of off about the
performance there seems like sebastian
stan is evidently not used to doing vo
work or maybe lack direction on it i
mean maybe it is just the quality of
those lines in combination with
something like that like maybe it didn't
come out as lived in as we had hoped
yeah it sounds like he's performing in a
booth yeah absolutely going for that
one-liner whereas like haley atwell
blends seamlessly yeah so does dominic
cooper yeah like a lot of them do and
then some don't as well and sebastian
stan unfortunately was one that was like
we just love pissed off a lot of people
because
bucky's everyone's favorite huh
maybe giving him like a scene scene
but in this case it is steve who dies
seemingly but actually falls into
hydra's clutches carter comes back and
interrogates zola with toby jones
returning to voice the character i will
tell you nothing
he told me everything and carter points
to castle crake on the map a name
evoking the word kraken which is the sea
monster of legend with similar giant
tentacles as the interdimensional beasts
that they end up facing there's another
long warner that follows carter running
i love
decades before shields project pegasus
would use it the same way this tentacled
creature with a mouth full of sharp
teeth is never named i guess it's
similar to the interdimensional beast
called the abilis
and i'm thinking it could be one of the
elder gods or many angled ones from the
2009-2010 realm of king's marvel comics
the future quasar the guardians of the
galaxy nova project pegasus versus the
revengers the many angled ones are
lovecraftian interdimensional beings
that look a lot like this one of them is
schuma gorath who's actually rumored to
appear in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness see i know this
multiverse stuff is getting harder and
harder to understand
in the marvel multiverse it seems like
you have timelines and universes which
are realities parallel to our own that
sometimes branch off from each other to
form new ones as we saw in loki but then
in between those timelines you have what
marvel seems to be calling dimensions in
realms that they say are beyond space
and time and these are the surreal acid
trips that we see like in the doctor
strange movies the dark dimension also
the quantum realm and i think in a
dimension like this is where the many
angled ones reside that could explain
how peggy carter ended up going through
that dimension to end up in the present
day much like scott lang's quantum realm
time dilation and avengers end game okay
disney plus needs to make some type of
documentary and it's all about teaching
you how the inner workings of the
multiversal multiverse 101
like an 80-minute one kevin feige yeah
be the presenter the ted talks
we need this yeah i wasn't confused
until i thought about it
that's 30 seconds then i was like all
right i'm a little lost now i never
bothered to question and i kind of just
roll with the punches now howard cannot
read the german controls but they
translate to voltage resistance capacity
charge close load reduction power supply
override and hydropower actually when he
cranks up that closed lever that is when
the portal begins to close he actually
mentioned spending a weekend with hedy
lamarr who is an austrian-born american
actress who's actually a major asset to
the allied war effort she co-invented
the radio guidance system that was
intended for torpedoes and she got a ton
of warbond sold so yeah someone you
could imagine howard stark bragging
about hanging out with carter picks up a
sword and with her shield she just looks
very much like an english knight there
is a captain britain in the marvel
comics brian braddock who leads
interdimensional captain britain core
and peggy actually mentioned braddock in
an off-screen line in endgame if we're
talking about futures for captain carter
i would love to see her organize the
captain britain core rogers and carter's
raincheck dance date from the movie
comes back here except carter is the one
sacrificing herself except she doesn't
die or go into ice she immediately
transports into the future the portal
opened by the tesseract in the project
pegasus basement and what looks like the
days before loki's arrival via that same
portal in avengers samuel l jackson
jeremy renner returned to voice nick
fury and clint barton and carter says we
won the war which is a bit of irony
considering she has arrived just in time
to help the avengers fight loki's
invasion her war is really just
beginning now again the producers plan
to make captain carter a returning hero
in this series she's confirmed to be in
an episode for season two and trailer
footage shows her talking to doctor
strange in a different episode maybe
from this season and personally i would
love to see a cameo of her in live
action like drifting in the background
of the multiverse of madness fighting
that typical beast like gandalf fighting
the ball rock that might just be me let
me know your thoughts down below and you
can support me rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks for watching bye
fantastic job my friend you've made me
appreciate this so much more except for
sebastian stan except for sebastian you
put points down for me for sebastian
stan who i walked out saying a plus
now a b-plus shows the power of an
influencer
influencing my thoughts and emotions
because i have no self-esteem of my own
guys subscribe to the real rejects but
more importantly subscribe to new
rockstars hit that like button
um
adelia chamberlain there's anyone at
this patreon who i know would throw
themselves into that machine take on the
super soldier serum in a clutch moment
of heroism it would be you plus i know
how much you love loki so this is
perfect timing because then when you go
through the portal you can meet your
heroes which is what everyone says you
ought to do i'm using my hands a lot
because you inspire me to move you're
out there getting more and more active
in the showdown community which is very
similar to you know like fighting big
interdimensional demons and you know
saving the world from tangible stakes so
keep up the good work adelia we love you
and especially greg loves you and
stay pledged
we'll see you soon
captain chamberlain
[Music]
you